on the History Channel series Pawn Stars
the experts at the world famous Gold &
Silver Pawn Shop and Las Vegas meet
regular folks with unusual objects to
sell sometimes worthless but often
surprisingly valuable here are some of
the biggest payouts in Pawn Stars
history Dutch East India Trading Company
Bell the woman who brought this 17th
century ships Bell into the shop was
actually considering putting it out on a
yard sale
Richard old man Harrison thought the
Bell had to be a reproduction but the
expert they brought in confirmed that it
was indeed a shipwreck Bell from 1602
and was worth a small fortune
$15,000 give or take 1715 Spanish fleet
gold coin in 1715 a Spanish fleet
carrying millions of pesos worth of gold
sank to the bottom of the ocean off the
coast of Florida lucky customer Jody
inherited an exceptional gold coin from
the shipwreck at first Rick Harrison
thought the coin was in too good of a
condition to be genuine but the expert
confirm that it was authentic was worth
a cool $18,000 from everything I can see
on this one
try say it's absolutely genuine Joe
Greene's Olympic medals Olympian jumpin
Joe Green came across hard times in the
late 90s so we sold the Harrison's his
Olympic bronze medals in the 1992 and
1996 games Rick reportedly assured in
the despite their $30,000 value he would
never sell the medals but in this world
everything has a price I'm asking
$20,000 for the Atlanta one 10,000 for
the Barcelona order of the white eagle
medallion a very lucky yardsale fanatic
picked up this medal for only 75 cents
and sold it to Rick for a cool $6,000 it
turned out the metal dated back to the
era of Tsarist occupation of Poland and
Rick eventually resold the medal for 30
grand Book of Mormon Adam got more than
he bargained for when an expert Rebecca
Romney appraised his fifth edition copy
of the Book of Mormon from 1842 I would
appraise this book actually at about
$40,000 Rick and Adam finally settled on
a purchase price of $24,000 and both
walked away happy with the transaction
15:54 Spanish shipwreck gold bar when
one man was cleaning out the belongings
of his grandfather he found a gold bar
hidden away in a box its meltdown value
alone was $24,000 but what an expert
confirmed it was from a 1554 Spanish
ship record the price doubled instantly
through telling me that's worth $48,000
in that neighborhood
yeah 2001 Patriots Super Bowl ring
Patriots defensive back brought Williams
had a hard passion he decided to pawn
his 2001 Patriots Super Bowl ring for a
modest $2,600 he never came back for it
and the rain became the property of the
shop while similar rings have sold for
around thirty thousand dollars on
auction websites Rick isn't ready to let
go of his favorite item anytime soon
which is why he set the sale price on
this beauty to a whopping $100,000 John
F Kennedy cigar box the biggest payout
ever on Pawn Stars is thanks to a piece
of presidential history a seller walked
into the shop with a box of cigars that
once sat on john f kennedy's desk in the
Oval Office
after some haggling Rick managed to
purchase JFK a cigar box for $60,000 for
comparison a similar JFK humidor was
purchased by the publisher of cigar
aficionado in 1996 for five hundred and
seventy-five thousand dollars thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos at the one
you just saw and leave us a comment to
let us know what you think of these pawn
star deals
[Music]